بقصه امل وانجاز طبي عربي بطلتها فتاه
مصريه تدعى سحر كانت تعاني من فشل تنفسيا
حاد واحتاجت لزراعه رئه عاجله تقدم شقيقها
للتبرع وجاءت فحوصات الانسجه متطابقه وبعد
اشهر من ترتيبات والفحوصات اجريت العمليه
بنجاح بعد نقل في الصين من رئه المتبرعين
شارك في العمليه 50 طبيبا من اطباء
الجراحه والاوعيه الدمويه والتخدير وبحضور
احد اهم خبراء زراعه الرئه بالعالم من
اليابان استغرقت العمليه التي اجريت في
مستشفى عين شمس التخصص بالقاهره نحو 24
ساعه متواصله في ثلاث غرف وفي ان واحد
العمليه تعتبر الاولى من نوعها في الشرق
الاوسط وافريقيا لانها تمت من متبرع حي
حسب الاطباء الحاله الصحيه لمريضه وشقيقها
سنويا اكثر من 4000600 عمليه زرع رئه في
جميع انحاء العالم وهو اجراء اخيل لانقاذ
حياه المرضى المصابين بفشل التنفسي الطبيب
الامريكي جيمس هاردي اجرا اول عمليه زرع
رئه بشريه في التاريخ عام
1963 لكن اول عمليه ناجحه كانت عام 1988
وهو اجراء تستبدل فيه الرئه المريضه برئه
سليمه او رئتين من متبرع متوفي اما اول
عمليه زرع ناجحه باستخدام فصوص من متبرعين
احياء اجريت في الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه عام 1996 لكن في الوقت الحالي
تعتبر جامعه كيوت في اليابان رائده لهذا
الاجرام وتحقق نتائج ممتازه تحتاجه هذه
العمليه غالبا الى متبرعين يتم ازاله الفص
السفلي من الرئه اليمنى من متبرع واحد
وازاله الفص السفلي من الرئه اليسرى من
المتبرع الاخر في نفس الوقت يتم ازاله
الرئتين من المريض المتلقي واستبدالهما ب
سرقه المتبرعين في عمليه واحده
[موسيقى]
ينضم الينا من القاهره من الطاقه الطبيه
دكتور محمد حسين مدير وحده زراعه الرئه في
مستشفى عين شمس التخصصي واستا جراحه الصدر
والدكتوره هبه عبد العظيم استاذت التخدير
ونائب مدير وحده رعايه المركزه بالمستشفى
عين شمس التخصصي يسعد صباحكما ويبارك لكم
هذا الانجاز العربي الكبير في صباح
العربيه اولا انجاز نجاح اول عمليه زراعه
الرئه من شخص حي في الشرق الاوسط وافريقيا
تفضلوا حدث لنا اكثر عن هذا الانجاز
والتفاصله
صباح الخير يا فندم اهلا وسهلا بيكي وصباح
الخير على السيد المشاهدين
طبعا هو انجاز الله ده انجاز فعلا كبير
وخطوه طبيه صداقه لجامعه عين شمس وايه
لمصر كلها ان احنا نبدا برنامج زراعه
الحقيقه برنامج زراعه الرئه اتاخر شويه في
البدايه في مصر ولكن الحمد لله احنا بدانا
وبدايه ناجحه صحيح البدايه كانت بدايه
صعبه شويه لان احنا بنعمل
استئصال الرئه من المتبرعين همم حيين همم
ونزل على الرئه للمريضه لكن الحمد لله تمت
بنجاح بفضل همم جهود وعلم
الطاقم الطبي كله همم وكانوا ناس على قدر
المسؤوليه وهمم
باحترافيه شديده جدا
دكتور محمد فقط قبل ان ادخل في التفاصيل
كم كانت درجه خطوره هذه العمليه وفرضيات
بالا تكلل العمليه بنجاح لا سمح الله
ده سؤال جميل
كبدايه للرد على السؤال هي نسبه الخطوره
في عمليات زراعه الرئه على مستوى العالم
هي 10%
ده نسبه الخطوره على الحياه فبالتالي في
نسبه 90% نجاح
الحقيقه في الحاله بتاعه البنت ديه لا
كانت النسبه تعتبر ضعف الكلام ده 20 الى
25% نسبه خطوره على الحياه وذلك لعده
اسباب اولا ان البنت عندها تليف رئوي شامل
الرئتين كاملهتين ثانيا في ضعف في عضله
القلب اليمنى اليسرى ثالثا في زياده في
ضغط الشريان الرئوي همم كبيره جدا كان ضعف
ضغط الدم العادي ضغط الشريان الرئوي كان
عندنا 130 على 80 ودوت همم نسبه كبيره جدا
فبالتالي نسبه الخطوره على حياه البنت ديت
كانت 20 الى 25% ولكن ربنا خلل جهودنا من
همم بنجاح ونظرا للنوايا الطيبه اولا من
اخواتها اللي كانوا همم مصممين على التبرع
وثانيا من البنت نفسها اللي كانت خايفه
على اخواتها اكثر ما خائفه على نفسها
لدرجه انها انسحبت من البرنامج لمده خمس
شهور ورجعت ثاني بعد ما حليتها سائل همم
والنوايا الطيبه للفريق الطبي كله والدعم
الكبير الغير متناهي اللي احنا اخذناه من
الدكتور محمود المتيني رئيس الجامعه عندنا
فالحمد لله ربنا كلل جلودنا جميعا بالنجاح
طيب دكتوره هبه يعني انت استاذ التخدير
العمليه كانت معقده اصلا كانت تعاني من
فشل تنفسي وكانت مهدده بالموت فعاليه الى
اي مدى كانت العمليه معقده تمت في 14 ساعه
في ثلاث غرف منفصله وبمشاركه العديد من
الدكاتره من كل اختصاصات تفضل عليه
[موسيقى]
اهلا وسهلا بكم طبعا العمليه دي كانت تمثل
بالنسبه لنا تشالنج كبير جدا
بتقولي سحر بنت 28 سنه بس هي كان عندها
مشكلتين كبيرتين جدا ان هي كان عندها تليف
في الرئه وفشل تنفسي حياه ناقص جامد جدا
في الاكسجين وده ادى ان حصل عندها ضعف في
عضله القلب وارتفاع عالي جدا في ضغط
الشريان الرئوي ده بالنسبه لنا كدكاتره
تخدير بيمثل تحدي خاصه اثناء الاندوكشن
بتاع العمليه او اللي هي بدايه التخدير
بس الحمد لله طبعا بيبقى فيه احتمال كبير
جدا همم لدرجه ان يحصل توقف العضله القلب
وبعد الشر ولا قدر الله الوفاه الحمد لله
بفضل التقنيات الحديثه الجامعه اا جابتها
لنا قبل العمليه والاجهزه
التخدير طبعا على درجه عاليه جدا لتخدير
الحالات الصعبه دي الحمد لله لا حاله عدت
بسلام مش بس كده طول العمليه احنا بنتكلم
في تقريبا 14 ساعه خلال الفتره دي المريض
بيتعرض لانخفاضات وارتفاعات في اا الضغط
والنبض والجهاز التنفس والاكسجين
وكل اعضاء الحيويه اا بدرجه عاليه جدا
ممكن تؤدي الى الوفاه في اي لحظه من
العمليه اا فالحمد لله ربنا سترها وقدرنا
نوصل اا ان احنا نعدي المرحله دي بسلام
عايزه اقول لحضرتك ان الخبير الياباني في
بدايه العمليه هو قال واحنا كلنا كنا
متفقين ان احنا مش هنيجي ناحيه الدهونر مش
هنبدا عمليه الدهونر الا لما نتطمن ان همم
الاندكشن بتاع سحر او بدايه عمليه سحر عدت
بسلام علشان اللون ما يتاذيش لان كان في
احتمال زي روحك يعني همم يحصل لا قدر الله
مش مشكله بس الحمد لله اه الحمد لله وصلت
عندنا في الرعايه المركزه
طيب راح نحكي عن هذا الموضوع ما بعد لو
عايزين تفضل
هاي النقطه بس فقط حتى نكسب كل المعلومات
دكتور محمد نتحدث معك يعني حول اليه
الجراحه نحن نعرف دائما زراعه الرئه
كمصطلح علمي يعني استبدال رئه غير سليمه
رئه ضعيفه مصابه باخرى سليمه ولكن تكون من
متوفي الى حي هذه المره من حي الى حي ما
المختلف كيف نفهم
ده سؤال رائع طبعا هي زراعه الرئه في اكثر
من 97% من المراكز على مستوى العالم هي من
متبرع متوفي حديثا الى ااا الى مريض حي
وطبعا دوت لازم اشيد برنامج في منتهى
الاهميه في منطقتنا وهو برنامج زراعه
الرئه في مستشفى الملك فيصل التخصصي في
الرياض وده اكبر برنامج في المنطقه وبيعمل
تقريبا 40 حاله في السنه وانا تشرفت ان
انا كنت استشاري همم في هذا البرنامج
ومديرا للبرنامج في اخر سنتين وتشرفت
الحقيقه في العمل فيه همم الطبيعي ان احنا
بناخذ رئتين الرئه الواحده الرئه اليمنى
ثلاث فصوص الر- اليسرى همم فصين ونزرع
الرئتين دول همم للمريض فبالتالي المريض
في الاخر همم
بيتزرع له خمس فصوص من الرئه الرئتين
كاملهتين وفي نفس الوقت انا ما عنديش قلق
وخوف غير على مريض واحد اللي هو المريض
المتلقي للرئه
على العكس في التبرع بالرئه من حي انا
باخذ فص واحد من متبرع اليمين فص واحد بين
المتبرع اليسار وازرع الفصين للمريض
فبالتالي انا عندي ثلاثه مرضى على على على
ترابيزه العمليات والثلاثه مرضى بيكون
شغالين معهم في نفس الوقت ثلاث غرف عمليات
همم جنب بعض فبالتالي الامكانيات البشريه
اللي محتاجينها والامكانيات التقنيه
الحقيقه اصعب كثير قوي من همم من التبرع
من متوفي حديثا وفي نفسه الوقت همم عدد
المرضى انا هنا قلقان على كم مريض قلقان
على ثلاث مرضى في المتبرع الحقيقي بينما
في المتبرع المتوفي انا قلقان على مريض
واحد فقط تقنيه المتبرع الحقيقه اصعب همم
ولكن الحمد لله زي ما قلنا نتيجه للتدريب
على سنوات سنوات وسنوات ربنا كل ال- اا
اللي عملنا دوت بالنجاح طيب الدكتور هبه
نسال اخيرا عن الوضع الصحي لسحر وشقيقها
بعد العمليه كيف هي حالتهم الصحيه
[موسيقى]
الحمد لله الاثنين دول عرس اشقاء سحر
حالتهم كويسه جدا والحمد لله خلاص هم
روحوا البيت
تمام الصحه الحمد لله همم بالنسبه لحاله
سحر الحقيقه حاله سحر كانت حرجه جدا حتى
في الرعايه المركزه
بس هي الحمد لله دلوقت الوضع مستقر وفي
تحسن يوم بعد يوم في تحسن اا يمكن احسن
حتى من توقعاتنا الحمد لله همم احنا سحر
بدات تفوق بدات تتكلم همم هي كانت طالعه
من العمليات على ادويه منشطه للقلب ودور
الدمويه لان زي ما قلت لحضرتك هي طبعا كان
عندها ضعفه في العضلات القلب حاليا هي
حاله القلب شغاله كويس جدا بدون اي ادويه
منشطه للقلب او الدوره الدمويه
الحاجه الثانيه برده اللي تقول لنا ان
احنا في تقدم ان هي احنا كنا على حاجه
اسمها
ده جهاز بيساعد ال- القلب او بيقوم بوظيفه
القلب والرقه الحمد لله قدرنا بفضل الله
انه يتفصل من على المريضه وحاليا هي على
نوع ثاني من الاسم وا عقيدا اسمه فيفي
اسمه ده مجرد ان هو مساعد للرئه لغايه لما
ان شاء الله تقوم بوظيفتها بحاله كامله
الحمد لله هي بدات التغذيه وبدات العلاج
الطبيعي اا والوضع فيه تقدم يعني الحمد
لله ان شاء الله باذن الله طبعا انا ما
اقدرش نطمنكم تماما ونقول ان حصل استقرار
تام قبل اا شهر ونصف يعني احنا بنقول ان
المريضه بتقعد من شهر ونصف لشهرين بعدها
هنقدر نقول ان الوضع استقرت تماما انما
الوضع في تحسن الحمد لله وبالتاكيد نحن
نستشرف في المستقبل وخصوصا فيما يتعلق
بزراعه هكذا عمليات من نوعها في منطقتنا
العربيه شكرا جزيلا لكما دكتور محمد حسين
مدير وحده زراعه الرئه بمستشفى عين شمس
التخصصي استاذ جراحه صدره دكتوره هبه عبد
العظيم
ونائب مدير وحده الرعايه المركزه مستشفى
عين شمس التخصص يعني